une tache noire dans le tableau mais qui
n'aura pas empêché les tourangejau
d'être au rendez-vous pour les
animations de Noël Léa Turquie et
Clémence dos qu'on fait le tour des
attractions et du Marché Gourmand vous
allez voir que l'ambiance des fêtes se
ressent
[Musique]
déjà il volle comme un air de fête dans
les rues de tour chalet gourmand et
marché de Noël s'installent jusqu'à la
fin de l'année dans les allées encore
cal s'élève une douce odeur de sucre et
de vin chaud certains se sont déjà
laissés aller atmosphère conviviale
chaleureux oui ça m fait penser à ma
famille et ça très beau souvenir on a
goûté le vin chaud du coup le Ponchaud à
la place de la Résistance et voilà on a
fait déjà fait tout petit tour de du
marché de Noël donc c'est plutôt cool
belle ambiance parce que là il y a pas
beaucoup de monde mais peut-être en
soirée en soirée vous allez faire quoi
je sais Pasir un petit verre peut-être
même plusieurs
fromage brezzel ou encore friandise
s'éparpille sur les étales se remplir la
pense avant ou après les manèges il
faudra être
stratégique à la nuit tombée les
lumières prendront le relais ambiance
garantie jusqu'au
[Musique]
réveillon